hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well the entirety of
Plato's symposium is supposed to be
speeches praising love there's some
framing material at the beginning that
we've talked about in another video of
course but the bulk of what's happening
are these six or actually seven let's
see also by ADIZ comes in speeches that
are in praise of something perhaps love
perhaps something else well we'll talk
about that in just a minute
but everybody is given the task of
praising luck now there's a lot of
interesting things we can ask about this
how should love be praised why should
love be praised and we we get that
second one at the beginning when they
decide that they're not going to drink
heavily during this this symposium this
drinking party but they're going to do
something else instead the suggestion is
well we should talk we should have a
banquet of words instead of dainty's and
and liquor so the question is what
should we talk about and erikson MCUs
recounts this discussion that that
Phaedrus had was a part of my favorites
is going to go first where if a dress
was complaining and saying you know
people give speeches about all sorts of
things and and they go through some
interesting examples even speeches about
salt the greeks like these epi
these these these speeches of praise you
know not just at say funerals or you
know my menses occasions it was kind of
a thing that they did you know talking
something up and Phaedra says why hasn't
anybody done any about love what is
really important why they avoided that
subject or if they'd forgotten it so
Eric Zemeckis and it says and everybody
agrees let's do that now that's the why
because it hasn't been done and it
should be done right love is a great God
love is this interesting thing that we
are motivated by that you know affects
our fates and destinies and we don't
completely understand so perhaps we'll
learn something in the process of all
these these really smart people talking
about it that we didn't originally know
we'll get a better handle on things and
we'll also get to hear some great
oratory as well now it's a good topic
like I put here for that particular
group why we see some cues about this in
the text Socrates hearing about this
topic says yeah I can do that I mean
it's one of the few things I actually
know anything about love I could talk to
you all about that of course later on
he's gonna say oh you know I think I may
have overplayed my hand a bit we'll see
why that comes up but it's not just
Socrates who's well suited to this it's
a lot of these other speakers as well
huffs audiences clearly put a lot of
thought into at least legal regimes and
how they affect the love relationship we
have a representative of comedy they're
one of the greatest comedy writers in
ancient Greece Aristophanes a poet we
have Agathon himself who's just won the
competition for tragedy so he is the
number one tragedy writer again a poet
in Greece while in Athens at that time
we have Socrates representing philosophy
we have you know a technical expert in
Eric's amicus and then we have a nice
looking you know fairly smart
well-spoken all-around kind of guy in in
Phaedrus presumably there's some others
that we don't actually know anything
about notice too that arista Dimas is
not going to give a speech in the course
of this even though technically he
should have he is the one who's
recounting the story to us but these are
these are a good group for presenting
this we're gonna get a banquet that has
a lot of different dishes that are in
different styles quite varied you know
counterpose to each other you know and
these are also some of the heavy hitters
in intellectual life in Greece there's
one other thing that makes it a good
topic for this group too some of them
are lovers of each other very clear post
audience and Agathon have a
long-standing love relationship going on
it's thought that Erikson mcus is a
lover of Phaedrus who by the way you
know it has other people who like him as
well we find out that Alcibiades has
this very strange love relationship with
Socrates where Elsa by ities who bursts
in at the end wants to be the beloved
but can't get Socrates to come through
on the deal the way that he's you know
supposed to when he's being seduced and
then you know Alcibiades really pulls
out all the stops since he tells us so
Alcibiades is himself madly in love with
Socrates Socrates is but the beloved and
the lover at the same time
Aristophanes is actually the only person
who is not in a relationship with
somebody in the room except for I guess
you could also say arista Dimas the
wrist of Demian Dimas is not a lover of
Socrates in any sort of you know sexual
or erotic sense now what's really
interesting about this as we're thinking
about this how should love be praised is
that as the speeches go on
as you read through you're gonna realize
these people are criticizing each other
and saying look buddy you thought you
were praising love but you weren't
really doing a good job on it let me see
if I can do a better job and maybe
explain a little bit you know where you
went wrong so Pausanias is going to you
know faders is going to give this this
wonderful little speech at the beginning
sort of if we're going to talk about
this some culinary terms really just in
a moose bush you know it's got a little
interesting you know taste to it it's
rather conventional it's short it's
sweet it's to the point love is the
oldest of the gods love is this great
bringer of benefits pal Sonia says
fingers you know you're doing a good job
but you actually left out a lot of the
picture because love can be good or love
can be bad and I mean to praise the good
love not the bad love but then let me
tell you about all this other stuff well
we'll get to that in a moment
Eric symmachus is going to do something
similar with pal sannyas he's gonna say
posta audience you started out great but
you didn't bring your speech to a
successful close
I'll take care of that for you through
my art of medicine that I'm going to
bring to bear Aristophanes is going to
criticize really by implication all of
the previous speakers he's going to say
before he tells his his funniest story
he says here we go if if we know who
love as he truly is surely we would have
raised the mightiest temples and altars
and offer the most splendid sacrifices
not utterly neglected him so I'm going
to take a different line than the rest
of you because I'm convinced that
mankind human and humanity has not
really had any conception of the power
of love which would mean these previous
speakers as well so Aristophanes is sort
of claiming that he now is being to
praise love the way that it want to be
praised
Agathon is going to say something
similar he's gonna he's going to tell us
that look all of you who have have given
it a good shot
but now I'm going to really praise love
because I understand what love is and
why he's to be praised turns out when
Socrates starts asking Agathon questions
engaging in dialectic then everything
that an Agatha you know put forward as
something that he knew he doesn't
actually know his whole speech falls
apart
Socrates before he gets into that he
says man you know when I got into this
competition or this you know rivalry or
whatever you want to call it with you
guys I thought that I was going to come
out on top because I thought that what
we were trying to do here was actually
tell the truth about love and praise
love through revealing what love
actually is not just come up with a
whole bunch of cock-and-bull stories
about love you know that a fine spun
nonsense just rhetoric the way you guys
have been doing so Socrates is actually
saying you shouldn't be praising love
that way you should be praising love the
way I'm going to do it now how did
Socrates actually do it what he brings
in this other character the only woman
in the story do it Emma and the autumn
at the very beginning is going to do the
same sort of questioning with Socrates
as he is doing with Agathon that's why
he says look I can help you out here
of your puzzlement I went through this
this whole same thing myself
let me tell you about that time is the
autumn atelic Socrates that he doesn't
have an adequate understanding of love
so I put a question mark here do de ma
if we want to call it a speech within a
speech do Donna is actually carrying out
a process what she calls initiation for
Socrates so I don't think that there's
any sort of explicit criticism going on
there but there is an implicit criticism
Socrates you don't actually know enough
about this let me actually help you with
this I didn't put Alcibiades here
because Alcibiades isn't there for the
other speeches so he doesn't really have
anything to say about anybody else's
speeches but he clearly does his own
thing right now here's the key question
to ask yourself as we're
as we're focusing in a praising love who
we actually did praise love did the
speakers praise love or did they end up
raising something else famous we could
at least say did praise love right he
may have gotten some things wrong but he
started out with love and ended with
love I think we can say that Socrates in
do Dhamma were praising love as well
they're doing more than praising love
they're they're trying to teach us or
lead us through this whole ladder of a
set to the greatest of beauty and and
you know they're praising other things
on the way but love is in there in the
mix it's not something that's great by
itself it's great because of what it
leads to what about these other guys is
Agathon praising love he certainly seems
to be but as it turns out he doesn't
really know much about love so kind of
you know the arrow misses the mark
what about pop science is he really
praising love or is he praising a
certain type of relationship I think
that's the case Erik Zemeckis is not
really praising love he's really
praising his art of medicine and thereby
the person who knows the art of medicine
himself
Aristophanes is in a certain respect
praising love but he's doing so through
this very funny story and he's
displaying his own technique his own art
his own abilities in poetry so there
might be a little bit of backhanded
complimenting of himself you know
involved in that so now that everybody
is praising love even though that's what
they're supposed to be doing so you
notice this question you know why and
how to praise love turns out to be quite
a bit more complex in the symposium than
you might first suspect it's when we
look at the speeches and we arrange them
in relation to each other that we see
how this actually works